>> Sean: SO ACCORDING TO THE
MEDIA RESEARCH CENTERS ANALYSIS
OF THE JANUARY AND FEBRUARY
EVENING NEWS CASTS ON ABC, CBS,
MSNBC, COVERAGE ON PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS 91% NEGATIVE.
SHOCKING.
WE HAVE SEAN SPICER WITH US AND
JOE CONCHA.
91% IS ALMOST EVERYTHING
NEGATIVE.
>> NINE OUT OF TEN STORIES.
MEDIA RESEARCH CENTER IS A
CONSERVATIVE OUTLET.
PUGH RESEARCH CAME TO THE SAME
CONCLUSION.
WE'RE TALKING NOT ABOUT OPINION
SHOWS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ABC, CBS,
MSNBC.
SUPPOSED TO BE NONPARTISAN.
24 MILLION PEOPLE WATCH THOSE
SHOWS A NIGHT.
THAT'S A LOT.
MORE THAN AVERAGE FOR THE WORLD
SERIES.
WHEN NINE OUT OF TEN STORIES ARE
NEGATIVE TOWARDS AN
ADMINISTRATION, THAT IS BIAS AND
BROAD DAYLIGHT.
WHAT YOU HAVE HERE IS A
PRESIDENT THAT IS OVER 40% IN
THE REAL CLEAR POLITICS AVERAGE,
OVER 50% IN THE ECONOMY ON
APPROVAL.
>> Sean: 48% IN ZOGBY, 58% IN
RASMUSSEN.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: HIS NUMBERS KEEP GOING
UP.
PEOPLE ARE ADJUSTING -- DONALD
TRUMP IS DIFFERENT.
HIS A DISRUPTER.
I THINK THEY LIKE IT AND IT WILL
HELP HIM IN THE RE-ELECTION.
THINGS HAVE GOTTEN SO BAD --
I'VE WATCHED YOU BATTLE THAT
IDIOT AT FAKE NEWS, ACOSTA.
IF THEY WANT TO CALL HIM A
JOURNALIST, THIS IS THE SAME
NETWORK THAT WE SAW GO DUMPSTER
DIVING IN ST. PETERSBERG AND NOW
THEY WENT TO A JAIL IN THAILAND
TO INTERVIEW A SEX COACH
THINKING THEY'RE GOING TO CRACK
UP THE TRUMP COLLUSION STORY.
>> FIRST OF ALL, BEFORE WE GET
OFF THE NUMBERS, I JUST WANT TO
SAY CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
RATINGS.
SEEMS THERE'S A NICE PATTERN
HERE WITH SEAN TO SUPPORT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOING REALLY
WELL IN THE RATINGS.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR SUCCESS.
THAT PROVES TO THE NETWORK NEWS
THAT TELLING THE TRUTH AND
GETTING THE STORY OUT IS WHAT
VIEWERS ARE TUNING IN TO SEE.
WITH RESPECT TO MR. ACOSTA, WHAT
THIS COMES DOWN TO IN THE RECENT
TWEET THAT HE SENT WITH RESPECT
TO SARAH SANDERS, HE SAID THAT
SHE BY NOT CALLING HIM DIDN'T
SHOW COURAGE.
LET'S BE HONEST.
JIM ACOSTA IS A CARNIVAL BARKER
THAT IS CLUELESS AND CLASSLESS.
THE DAY THAT BRIEFING WAS TAKING
PLACE, SARAH ANSWERED OVER 40
QUESTIONS.
BECAUSE JIM DIDN'T GET HIS
QUESTIONS IN, HE FEELS THAT
SHOWED A LACK OF COURAGE.
ON THAT SAME DAY, SARAH HAD TWO
COMBAT VETERANS ON STAGE THAT
JUST MET WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHO HE THANKED FOR THEIR
SERVICE.
ST. JOHN PECK AND SERGEANT LIAM
DWYER.
THEY WERE INJURED IN IRAQ
SEPARATELY, WENT BACK AND
REENLISTED TO GO TO IRAQ.
BOTH CASES, BOTH GOT FURTHER
INJURED.
SERGEANT PECK LOST BOTH HIS ARMS
AND BOTH HIS LEGS.
STAFF SERGEANT DWYER LOST AN
ARM.
HE HAS HAD OVER 50 SURGERIES.
THAT, MR. ACOSTA, IS COURAGE.
THAT IS COURAGE.
DON'T TALK ABOUT NOT GETTING A
QUESTION BEING A LACK OF
COURAGE.
COURAGE WILL SERVE THIS COUNTRY
AND ACT LIKE AN ADULT.
>> Sean: WELL-SAID.
LAST WORD.
>> FOX NEWS IN THE FIRST YEARS
OF PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
CONFERENCES, 36 PRESS
CONFERENCES.